brady singer yeah how about it singer
he's got something for him here
brady singer will throw a change up
occasionally they'd like to see more
though as he continues to develop
jonathan india
digs in against his former college
teammate india is enjoying this more
than brady brady brady's
all business i didn't see much of a nod
back and there's a
pop-up to wit to begin the game see if
there's any words being mentioned right
here
nothing i love it one on one out to
tyler stevenson
not this time stevenson strikes out and
there are two down in the first well
like i said if you haven't seen him
before you want to see as many pitches
as you possibly can
but that runner it starts out on the
outside part of the plate and it breaks
all the way to the inside part of the
plate that's a fooler for a lot of guys
and the veteran joey votto is the dh
today
another one that's a swing so no
problems in the first hitting today for
brady singer
sunny gray his numbers from western and
southern
he was sizzling in his returned from the
injured list
still looking for a second win of the
campaign
first pitch right to first base and
tyler stevenson
shaded off the bag oh where that big
broad smile
brilliant pick one away first time back
out there at first base in a while
that ball will find you and it had a
little bit of downward action
top spin to it stevenson gets one quick
out now ben and tendy
up the middle perfectly shaded
freeman onto first two down now carlos
santana
giant lead for perez he's nearly at the
cut two outs full count he goes
oh fastball strike three buries it
in on the edge of the plate barnhart and
gray get it done
tyler naquin full kind of three and two
wit is perfectly lined up in shallow
right field
one down in the second inning two down
and now tucker barnhart who appears in
the series for the first time
ooh watch out over there that goes into
the royals dugout
john mabry watch out man that dropped
him off the front step
get that thing out of here let it go
brady three up three down in the second
and that's singer's third strikeout
watch out if you're sitting in that
dugout now and you're just not paying
attention
[Applause]
good recovery great peaks at first
o'hearn held on
solaire might have broke his bat
back to gray flipped to first one
stevenson fired down the second run down
o'hearn stumbles
and india applies the tag double play
one three four that was some kind of
different double play
i mean a full swing and this was
not one of those balls that you were
talking about being hard
no sir
[Laughter]
you see sonny he's kind of like all
right that's a hot potato let me get rid
of it
but he gets rid of it so quick that
stevenson has an easy
play at second base big opportunity here
for solaire
now what will solaire do here if he gets
a strike 2-0
swing broken bad ground ball slow roller
to third
out at second and then a collision india
and o'hearn
and safe at home plate o'hearn and india
are both down
o'hearn lost his helmet india is
grabbing his right hand but
that didn't look like there was any
chance for a double play but india was
going to throw
he hit o'hearn instead and it was a
painful way to get a run but that's
how the royals take the lead i'll say
man i gotta see this again now it saws
him off once again
low exit velo get one out and yeah you
know heard was already
hit the base and he was coming up that's
unusual there o'hearn
gonna be okay i hope look at that slide
really nice job letting
his momentum of his body carry him and
then drag the hand across the plate
the batter is michael taylor with two
out and two on
michael swings and lifts one to left
field that's a base hit here comes
solaire
the throw to third offline and the
royals make it two-nothing as solaire
checks in and the royals take that
two-nothing lead over cincinnati
sonny gray he's saying man i'm making
some good pitches
but they're getting hit now last ball
obviously the dozier was a
ball in the middle but there's a little
slider hits it off the end of the bat
and taylor got a couple of soft hits
today and he'll take both of them that
one with an rbi attached to it would be
his 32nd look at vance wilson boy he
he feels it for the runner doesn't he i
mean he gets he goes sliding as the
runners coming in from third
stevenson is struck out twice once on a
fastball once on a slider brady singer
has struck out six
and that sounded like the bat and the
royals are going to argue this
now stevenson can win an academy award
right now
but the royals are going to go to the
tape that sure sounded like the bat and
for his sake i hope it was the bat
because that was a big crack
oh no i got him that got him on his
wrist top of the wrist the royals dugout
reacted because they heard the crack but
they will not challenge and stevenson is
on to begin the sixth inning
joey votto two balls two strikes
grounded sharply wit makes a backhand
play
that's dozier the cover man and a double
play
that was two tough plays for with the
catch and then figuring out who to throw
to at second base better believe it good
hands man right there whitmerfield but
you know they're in
total communication all the time before
the pitch so they know who's covering
dozier he goes ahead nikki lopez
couldn't get there so dozier takes over
just like his old shortstop days back at
his university he went to
got the number nine hit her up and mike
freeman now he's all for two today 182
hitter on the season
he has a little bit of speed and freeman
base hit to left field wave is on for
barnhart ben intended
looks back the middle runner he concedes
the score and the reds are in good shape
as they push one across
and turn the lineup over to jonathan
india the reds have scored
the third most runs in baseball in the
seventh inning and later jonathan india
has been right in the thick of a lot of
those rallies
and he hammers that pitch to left field
down base head
threaded fair akiyama scores freeman
around
third ending at the second frame and
scores
and the reds ahead powered by the rookie
jonathan india a two run double
three two cincinnati so sonny gray
pitches with the lead for the first time
in
over the past three innings setting down
the last seven here we are bottom of
seven
michael taylor pinpoint sonny gray
five strikeouts eight consecutive royals
retired
lopez in taps the plate waves is bad
swing and a miss breaking ball strike
three
back-to-back hayes and nine consecutive
royals
retired by sonny gray well if you're
with maryfield you've got to guard
against the comeback fastball that
starts off the plate away and comes back
to the outside
corner and the breaking ball swinging a
miss he struck him out
sonny gray's best inning he strikes out
the side in the seventh
he's retired 10 in a row akiyama to the
plate
suarez off second 3-1 akiyama blazes a
fair ball
just inside the chalk suarez rounds
third
he scores akiyama connects
a two out run scoring double a big
insurance run four two reds
red's trying to add the lead in the
ninth it is four to two with
india at third base and stevenson over
at first
the o2 pitch wind
left center splashes down base hit
india scores more insurance for the reds
a 5-2 advantage on naked's second knock
of the day the last man standing is
whitt merrifield
0 for four five two reds trying to get
out of here with a series victory
ground ball backhand freeman
in time a one two three nine
hembree bolts down the save the
cincinnati reds
take the series they beat the royals in
the rubber match
five to two